Bonjour pas de pitié pour nous
day trader pitié vous voyez un monsieur aucune
attitude entre chaque partie ne fait pas la casserole le
rendez-vous de jinusean Wendy n'est pas fami
William khuddam Oh avec maman c'était / j
ai pissé d'innombrables Davi rit un moi
quinze ans ce n'est pas long pour  fils
pour obtenir le père de Noah, tu avais une vie bien remplie
, mais nous communiquions au golf, au
hockey, au poker et à moi
et à beaucoup d'autres aliments merveilleux.
les jeunes frères à mesure qu'ils
grandissent sans que tu sois là je ferai en
sorte de transmettre ce que j'ai appris
de toi tu es un acte difficile à suivre
mais avec ton L tout
ira bien
papa je te promets ici que nous '  tout
va être à la hauteur de vos normes